[Music]
okay everybody i am absolutely thrilled
today because i am joined by erica
wilson reed aka sabrina in the witcher
and season two is out on netflix now
erica how you doing today
i'm really good thank you yeah i've um
i just finished watching it twice so i'm
really excited for everyone to see it i
think
this season
i mean the first season was good and
this season is even better so i'm so
excited for everyone to see it
yeah it's an awesome just thrill ride
this season and it's exciting to see you
back in it but what i'm wondering is how
did you originally land the part of
sabrina
um
god it really was like a dream come true
i'm not gonna lie so
i had played the games before way back
when
and
not been very good at them and sort of
forgot about them and i was doing all
these cast and direct workshops and
just sort of trying to make it as an
actress and faye timby who was part of
sophie holland's casting department
she saw me and she recommended me to
sophie for the part of sabrina so
i got these sides come through
and i had no idea it was for sabrina and
i was so excited and i bought all the
books and i was reading them trying to
find this mysterious character
and um then i did this self tape and i
went in i met stevie holland and that
team is
just the nicest there
they're just a brilliant team to work
with they make you feel so comfortable
and then sort of two days later i got
the part sabrina and my life sort of
massively changed yeah
and that's cool that's cool that you
read the books and play the games and
like can understand the significance of
sabrina and like from my perspective
knowing more about the games like how
awesome of a part she has in which are
two um do you do you game at all in
general or is it kind of just the
witcher you kind of played
so i do try and game i'm not
the best at all but i do really enjoy it
and with witcher
i obviously tried gaming before
and i think it was just maybe a bit too
complicated when i first started
but i've recently got into it again so
i've got my nintendo switch and i'm
currently disappointed
i'm currently um on the family matters
quest and i'm trying to kill a botchling
i'm finding it very hard
um
but you know it i think it's just so
important having the books and having
the games and you've obviously got fans
of the books and found the games and
as a character within that universe
it's just so interesting kind of
learning everything you can and and
knowing the backstories of all the
different characters and and knowing all
the beasts that you may or may not run
into and and you get all these tidbits
just from from reading and from playing
those games and so yeah so i'm i'm
trying to get way back into it and
trying to get better i'm definitely not
an expert in any kind of gaming capacity
but i do try my best
look you sound like an expert to me that
that's really cool and exciting to hear
that you're into the games um and what
when it feels a lot like the games to me
was even in the season one
battle of sadan hill um
you got to do your character this like
really cool archery
did you have to train at all for that
so
i was so excited about being on this set
and playing this part that i remember
lauren is brilliant as a showrunner and
she makes time for everyone and she was
on set
nearly
as much as she could basically every
single time she could she was on set and
i went up to her and i was like i'm so
excited about this part i'm so excited
about sabrina do you mind if i send you
an email with all my thoughts and we
have a talk and she was like 100 yes so
i sent her this email um
kind of saying everything that i'd
learned was that kind of what she saw of
the character and asking what she saw in
terms of the journey of sabrina and she
mentioned that sabrina was into archery
and that that was something they were
going to maybe explore in the show
and so i immediately went home and i
wasn't asked to i went home
and booked archery lessons because i
thought it was just so important for
embodying the part of sabrina so i went
home i booked archery lessons
um i do have to say i'm i'm good when
i'm in a gym and all the targets are
stationary it's a very different
experience when um
you know you're at battle and you have
to do everything very quickly but um yes
so it wasn't something that i
necessarily needed to do but i thought
it was
really important for the show and for
the showrunners and for myself
as
sabrina to
be able to know how to do it
yeah and that's awesome that you put in
that effort for anything in your part
that's really cool and actually
inspiring for actors and actresses
listening to this
um and what was really cool just all in
that moment in the season is when
there's this big moment when yen and
sabrina fall from the tower and yeah you
should you share it on your instagram
you know which is like a glimpse behind
the scenes and you were suspended by
this wire in the air
talk to you about that was was that like
terrifying to do it looks terrifying
so i think
both anna and i were
so invested in doing as much of the
stunt as possible so
where i explode out the tower is not me
it's the stunt double but in terms of us
falling and landing that was something
we both
wanted to do ourselves and we had the
most amazing you know stunt team and um
amazing
amazing crew that allowed us to do it
and kept us really safe but it's kind of
like going on a rollercoaster like once
you once you do it once the first time's
a bit scary but once you do it once
you're like okay this is this is really
fun and also for me it was my last time
on set in season one as sabrina so
i was rinsing it for all it was worth i
wanted to do as much as possible yeah
and i mean from my perspective watching
that scene i was terrified that you know
some way somehow we lost sabrina and
that was it so
were you as an actress worried at all
that your character may be even if you
didn't die but wasn't going to be in
season two did i ever like run through
your head and is there a time maybe you
were confirmed to come back
um
i think just being part of the witcher
family is in itself a blessing and i'm
you know so proud of everyone and
and um
i think that
i wasn't necessarily sure i don't think
you're ever sure in those situations you
you know that in this universe anything
could happen to any of the characters
so
for me
i was
i was i decided that i was gonna do the
most i could for that season one and if
i was in future seasons then that would
you know it would just
mean everything to me but also you you
know that there's a particular storyline
they're going down
and um it's important that they follow
that storyline and push the storyline
forward and sometimes that means that
you're included and sometimes that means
that you're not but you know it's the
best of reasons
yeah that's that's a really good pro
answer too i like that and like it's a
good attitude to have and
it's interesting you mentioned like how
there's all these different journeys and
things that can happen in this universe
what i think it's exciting about you
having the character of sabrina is like
this is this big netflix witcher
universe now we already see they had a
cartoon and they're also doing a
spin-off series um does it excite you
the endless possibilities of where even
like sabrina could show up in any of
these forms
oh my god a hundred percent i mean
look if i could play sabrina until i was
100 i would
you know and um
and i love the world and i also love the
castle crew and
lauren and sophie holland and everyone
has
done an incredible job of making it like
a family so whether you're on set for
one day as a you know one scenario
you're on on set every single day you
walk on set and it feels like family and
it feels like you know you just have
this ex extended amount of love and even
throughout covid they still manage to
maintain that so
for me whether i'm in future seasons
whether i'm in it a lot or whether i'm
in a bit or whether you know something
does happen to sabrina it's it's just
been such a pleasure to continue in this
family and and i think that
you know every time i get to player even
for a minute it's a blessing and i love
it i love you yeah
okay so you love her so interesting too
so like when you first observe the
character and making the character your
own did anything jump out to you on the
page or from the games like that was
like oh i see erica there like that you
see yourself in sabrina any any parts of
her
i mean i think that when you get a
character you know when you book a job
you probably recognize that there's
probably aspects of yourself within that
character um but she's you know
she's ultra confident she's ultra sexy
she's incredibly ambitious she's got a
lot of pride i mean she's most powerful
influential resources in the northern
kingdom
like she you know she tells kings to
shut up and they listen to her and so i
think that the elements of that which
are inside me as they're okay you do
have to amplify them um and sort of
create
something more because she just has you
know this incredible power and i think
that
i think that also she has this frenemy
relationship between her and jennifer um
and
i think that's also something that's
really fun to play with um
and i think you know the girls on set
are really tight-knit and you know i do
cross them it's like my really good
friends and so i have that i have that
love for all those girls um and just
having that little bit of banter is just
um you know it's fun to add into it
yeah and i think that's what's cool too
it looks like you guys are having fun
on set and doing the shows and it comes
out in the performances in particular
yours and you know what's awesome too is
that you make such an impact whenever
you're on the screen that i mean you are
so popular to this with your fan base
that there is if erica wilson read
reddit how does that make you feel even
seeing that
um
gosh i haven't seen it but oh it's there
oh is it
um
look the the fans make the show and i
think that when you sign up to a project
like this you know you've got some
incredible fan of the books incredible
fans of the games and um and i think
that everyone feels really thankful for
them it's you know there's people
watching the show that means it
continues um and
you know i'm so thankful that you know
people enjoy the character of sabrina
and like her and want her to continue in
the shows like that means
it means the most to me you know as an
actor that they do enjoy my performances
so i'm really thankful for that and you
know i've done a few comic-cons and
meeting people who love the show
is one of the funnest parts of my job
you know i love talking to people and
finding out what bits they loved what
bits you know they didn't like so much
maybe or um what bits you know what
characters they love and and and having
having that conversation with them is so
exciting and it's so fun so yeah i mean
i i love all the fans love them that no
that's that's good to hear that you
appreciate that and like
it's interesting too you have all this
passion for it and
i'm wondering as well like you know
you're also a writer so you write you
act you've written a short in 2016
called the waiting game
um can we expect more writing coming
from you in the future
and
what's the ultimate dream for therapy
wilson read at the end of the day like
what gets you going in the morning where
do you want to see yourself kind of
thing
um
i think you know writing is always
something that's a you know in the
background i love doing it that was
something for me that i was you know
just sort of understanding film and so
for me to write something and then put
it on
was um
was really exciting and and i think
taught me a lot about how things get
filmed and how things get written and
what translates and what doesn't so
that's always something that's in the
background it's probably not something
that you're going to see for me in the
next six months um but yeah it's always
there and in terms of ultimate dreams i
think
you know
i think if it wasn't concrete before
which it was
having covered and not being able to act
not being able to do those things
really showed me how much i i love the
job that i'm you know lucky enough to be
able to do
and being back on set for that first
time was
just made you feel so emotional that you
were able you were able to do that so
for me it's concentrating on acting and
kind of
pushing that and seeing where that goes
and and i mean there's some really
exciting things happening so that's sort
of my
what i'm concentrating on at the moment
i that's exciting it's inspiring and you
know it makes fans excited to see what
you're going to do next what we're going
to see is sabrina next but everybody
obviously if you want to see dark wilson
crush it as sabrina check out the
witcher season 2 it is on netflix now
you can binge all of it
erica thank you so much for joining me
today and i hope to talk to you in the
future
thank you it's such a pleasure thank you
so much